欢迎收听星期的若可可播客我是施宇。
今天想跟大家聊的是上网这件事带给我的一些思考。
我想人只要上过网你就一定和别人吵架，
或者说一定旁观过别人吵架。
很多时候你去看互联网上的一些骂战，
你会发现有时候可能别人并没有表达这个意思，
但是在另一个人看来他接收到的信息却是，
你在指责我或者你在攻击我。
我自己也会有说错话，
表达得不清楚，被人误解，被人批评的时候。
同时我也有觉得自己被别人冒犯了，
觉得别人在指责我自己，
但其实人家并没有那个意思的时候。
这变成一个越来越常见的现象，
以至于我们其实能看到他背后藏着的是一种巨大的不安全感。
就好像我们一直处在一个警报状态，
双眼，双耳随时随地都在准备好去扫描外界，
朝我们设来的剑，
要随时进入一个防御状态，
来低防身边的所有言语中的这些名强案件伤害到我们。
当然前提是因为的确我们正身处在一个巨大的不安全感的时代。
我想我们其实正在经历着和遭受着空前的痛苦，
以及对这些痛苦我们有了比上一代人更加充分的意识。
我们能够看清自己身上的这些窗章去自我理解，
却不知道到底该怎么面对它。
所以我们会本能的希望还有一个解释。
它需要被指向说一定有人需要为此负责。
我感受到的痛苦一定是有人做错了什么，
而我是他的错误的受害者。
甚至有些时候人们在互联网上彼此攻击的方式。
已经不再是论证说谁更正确谁更错误，
而是论证谁受到的伤害更多谁更惨，
谁比谁更是一个受害者。
所以今天想和大家聊一聊什么是受害者文化。
以及为什么我们每个人都更倾向于觉得自己才是那个受害者。
我小时候一直有一个非常好奇的问题，
就是假如有一天你在学校被人欺负了，
被人揍了一顿，
你的反应是会觉得说你觉得这件事很丢人，
所以你想要藏起来不让别人发现你被人打了这一顿，
想要遮盖你脸上那些鼻青脸肿的痕迹，
还是说你的反应是想立刻公之于众，
让大家都看到你身上的这些欲伤，
来获得大家的同情和关心呢。
这边后其实包含的是两种不同的道德范氏，
也就是一个人他在社会上生活什么东西是更重要的。
有一个美国社会学家在受害者文化的新奇这本书里面，
提到过三种不同的道德范氏的变迁，
首先最开始是荣誉文化 owner culture，
他意思是每个人会对自己的名誉高度敏感，
如果受到了任何羞辱都需要用最直接的最暴力的方式来反击和回应，
比如说你被人揍了一顿，
你就一定要打回去证明你的武力值比他更强，
这种暴力和勇气会带来一种荣誉的身份，
而如果你向第三方比如说警察老师去求助，
就会被视为一种软弱，就会丧失这个荣誉感。
后来随着社会现代化和法治化的发展，
荣誉文化逐渐过渡成了一种尊严文化，
Dignity culture,。
他的特征是认为每个人最重要的一种内在价值就是尊严，
所以在这个社会上更加受到尊重的被认可的应对冲突的方式是，
强调我很坚强，
棍棒和石头会打断我的骨头，
但是伤害不了我，
我不会被外界的这些微小的冒犯伤害，
因为我有一个坚强的自尊心，
所以他会更加提倡人用非暴力的方式，
去进行协商沟通和对话，
而如果真的出现了严重的伤害，
就要尋求一个公正客观的第三方，
比如说法律来进行调解，沟通和解决，
认为这才是更文明的，
这种文明赋予的人尊严感。
而第三种道德范氏就是受害者文化Victimhood Culture，
他既包含了荣誉文化中人们对被羞辱这件事的敏感性，
又包含了尊严文化中人们必须要尋求一个第三方机构来做一个公正的审判，
所以他的特征是人们对微小的甚至无意识的一些冒犯变得非常敏感，
但是你回应这些冒犯的方式不是直接反击他，
而是呼吁一个外部第三方，
不管是社会的舆论还是说一个权威的机构，
来认可你的受害者身份并帮助你惩罚这个冒犯者，
因为他是一个加害者。
所以我们可以看到随着这三种道德范氏的变迁，
我们当今来到了一个受害者文化越来越流行的时代，
而他的核心机制就在于道德的意涵变得越来越重要，
他所带来的影响和反馈甚至已经超过了过去我们所说的荣誉和尊严，
而受害者这个身份则是最具有道德属性和道德资本的一个身份。
那在谈论受害者文化的流行之前，
我觉得我们可以先退一步看他的一个初级版本，
也是我个人认为2025年很多公共事件背后都传递出的一个时代情绪，
那就是字魔。
如果要我给2025年一个年度心态的话，那一定就是字魔。
很多人可能不一定听说过字魔这个词啊，
魔是荣摩摩的魔，
他最早的元气是来自同人文圈层啊，
就是功受双方，
然后如果你将一个人物放置到受的这个角色形象上，
你其实就要对他进行一定的脆弱化、课题化的处理，
让他显得更加的楚楚可怜、招人连爱。
所以如果你把一个人物理解成这种脆弱的值得连爱的形象，
那么就叫做摩他。
那当这个事情逐渐流行起来之后，
其实会有一些角色，
可能自己也会更有意识地展现出一些自己更加脆弱的、
值得被连爱的弱势的形象。
这种行为就被叫做字魔啊，
就是我自己选择展现我这种弱势的方向。
那随着这个文化不断的流行和加深，
慢慢的字魔被演变到了社会生活的更多方面中，
它本质上指向的是这样一种情绪。
那就是我们在社会生活中、在社会互动中，
总是会感到没有被公平的对待、
没有被好好的对待的一种委屈感。
而这种委屈感是需要被体谅、
被心疼和被理解的。
这些苦难是需要被看见和被承认的。
就像我们刚开头举的那个例子一样，
如果我被人揍了一顿，
那么我其实会希望大家能够看见我身上鼻青连种的伤痕，
然后来心疼我，温柔地体谅我、合理地关心我。
在这里我并不是要批评和指责这种心态，
很明显它成了一个如此流行的东西，
我自己也过些其中。
我也会总有受伤的忍不住想要被人关心和心疼的时刻，
觉得自己委屈的时刻。
它是一种如此广泛存在的现象，
所以我们今天在这里并不是说要简单粗暴的划分，
谁对谁错，或者你有权委屈还是无权委屈，
有权字魔还是无权字魔。
只是我们把它当作一个社会现象来好好看一看，
我们从它身上能得到哪些思考，
它是否真的能够帮助我们，我们该如何理解这件事情。
带着字魔这种心态你会发现，
2025年的很多网络热耕其实都是和这种心态有关的，
比如说蓝阳阳的表情包，
对吧，我是最棒的勇敢的小阳，
嗯，我已经很棒了，今天做到这样已经很棒了。
比如说我们对原生家庭的控诉，
东亚开头的这个词已经几乎成了某种社交货币，
但家讨论事情严避成东亚，
我们谈到亲密关系的创伤，
那我会觉得我是一个焦虑型一链，我有很多不安全感，
那追本溯源肯定和我的原生家庭，
我没有被父母好好爱过多少有些关系，
以及丝瓜汤对吧，
原生家庭带给我们的不被尊重，
不被看见的创伤。
我觉得随后这些现象的流行，
背后反映的一个本质需求是，
我们现在非常非常需要弄清楚自己的痛苦，
以及它的来源，
一定要弄明白我们为什么会痛苦，
以及谁应该为此负责。
因为如果我们无法改变正身处在这种痛苦情绪中的现实，
那特意万不讲至少我的这种痛苦的感受，
应该被人看见和被人承认吧。
我想在一次次发帖一次次互联网上的讨论中，
它实际上给的是一种最低程度的互相确认，
那就是我受到的伤害，
你也受到了这样的伤害，
我们作为同类人至少我们看见了，
承认了我们都受到过伤害，
这是一种最低限度的彼此抚摸和彼此安慰。
这也让我想到了前段时间听读书不成领袖一起节目，
讨论互联网上的生态，
其中一个我觉得启发很大的观点是共识这个词。
其实人和人之间所有的沟通和交流都一定要基于某种共识的，
比如说你在真实生活中与人相处，
你们是知道对方的一部分历史和他的一部分生命经验的，
比如说我们来自同一个学校，我们是同学，
那我知道你大概是个什么样的人，
你的家庭大概是什么样的，
所以我知道是什么东西什么，
生活经历造就了现在的你，
而我能够给出一个相应的反馈。
当你说出一句话的时候，
我大概知道他背后其实是因为你的什么经历你的哪些想法，
让你会在此刻选择说出这样一句话，
以及这句话的含义是什么，
所以我会给出一个相应的反馈，
沟通就可以这样顺畅地进行下去。
但是在互联网上你会发现，
正在跟你对话的这个人，
或者正在跟你吵架的这个人，
你们之间是没有任何共识的，
你对他没有任何了解他的历史，
他的来处一切都是空白的。
所以在互联网上当一切的共识都消失，
而我们仍然渴望和对方进行沟通和交流的时候，
我们唯一能够端出的最大公约数的一个共识，
似乎就变成了我们的窗商，
我们共同的窗商。
当我们之间想要进行一些正面的，
好的情感和沟通理解的时候，
它会建立在窗商的基础之上，
对吧，我们都被原生家庭这样对待过，
我们都在东亚的这套教育体系下成长起来，
被剥夺了同样的东西，
所以我们能够相互看见，
我们的对话是基于这种相互理解进行的，
窗商成了一个相互理解的语料库。
那另一方面，在一些不那么友好的线上对话中，
你感觉到被人误解和被人攻击，
你就会想要别人更了解你自己，
你想要解释自己说，
要么我不是这个意思，
要么是你不该这样攻击我，对吧。
你就想要端出自己的一部分历史，
一部分生命经验来让它理解说，
为什么我表达的其实是这个意思，
不是你理解的那个意思。
而这时你能端出的东西也只有两样，
一种要么是我受到的伤害，对吧。
我被这样对待过，
我有这样子的窗商和相应的应急的反应，
所以我会进行这样的表达，
以及我被这样伤害过，
我是一个受害者，
你怎么可以这样对我说话，
这样是不公平的。
或者另一端的共识就是，
那我要端出我取得的成就，
我这么厉害，
我是一个成功者，
你怎么可以这样对我说话，
我比你更正确，比你更优秀。
但你会发现，
即使是看似在争论成就，
争论谁更对，谁更错，
它背后重要的往往也不是说。
要争一个对错高下，
而是对错背后的一个情感倾向，
比如你发扎你和你妈的聊天记录，
说你妈误解了你，
你不是这个意思什么的，
但其实重点并不在于。
论证你妈妈的意思是A，
你的意思是B，
她是否误解了你，
不是做一个句子上席，
她背后真正渴望的是听到说，
你妈妈这样做的确误会和伤害了你，
你辛苦了，你受委屈了，
我们能看到你的委屈，
以及我的妈妈也这样，
我也受过同样的委屈。
所以我们会看到，
在当下的受害生活中，
受害者叙事，
或者说受害者的身份。
成为了一种解释框架，
他能够最低成本，
又最快速，最便捷的，
让人表达出，
我是一个什么样的人，
以及我所渴望的那个东西是什么，
也最方便的能让和你同类的人。
理解你，
与你聚拢，
相互安慰，
相互抚摸。
也正义如此，
受害者身份成了一种解释框架，
受害者文化正在变得越来越流行。
在我看来，
受害者文化其实具有两大特性，
第一个特点是美德性，
第二个特点是竞争性。
美德性的意思是，
你不仅需要是一个受害者，
受害者这个身份，
不仅只像说你受过伤，
他一定要配套绑定另一个特点，
那就是，
我是一个好人，
我是具有美德virtual的。
有很多研究受害者序式的文献。
都提到这样一个词，
virtuous victim hood,。
美德受害者，
或者德行受害者，
一个人他不仅需要表明受过伤，
来吸引他人的同情，
他同时需要释放出美德的信号，
那就是，
我具有高尚的品质，
我有某些美好的特质，
让人觉得我是值得被帮助的。
当这两者结合在一起的时候，
就会形成一种最有利的社会身份。
比如我们可以看到，
长期来在娱乐圈最流行的一个人生模板，
就是美强惨。
为什么我们很容易对美强惨这个身份上头呢？
因为他不仅惨，
他如果只是惨是不够的，
他一定同时需要美和强，
这是两种让人觉得他其实是一个好人，
是一个道德高尚的人，
是一个遭受了不公对待，
更需要我们去帮助的人。
而通过支持这些具有美德的受害者，
通过应援这些美强惨，
我们本质上是能够让作为看客的。
我们的委屈也被看见。
我看到了身为美强惨的你这么不容易，
那我一定要帮助你，
我一定要让你得到公正的对待，
本质上填补的是我们自己内心那种，
也想被公正对待想要被补偿，
对一种怠长的心理。
另一方面呢，美德这件事，
道德这件事，
它不光是一个高尚的品质，
它还具备另一个特点，
那就是它是一个有限的资源，
美德的这个市场，
你可以说它是一个零和博弈，
一方面人们的关注和注意力是有限的，
另一方面人们往往大脑结构上，
或倾向于有一种道德二元论，
那就是这个世界里的所有角色，
基本上都可以在道德这个维度上，
被简单粗暴的话为两类，
一类是道德的失动者，
也就是更接近于加害的一方，
另一个是道德承受者，
也就是那个更接近于受害的一方，
我们倾向于把所有的人，
都在道德普悉上划分为这两个维度，
也就是说，
一个人一旦他的受害者身份被确认，
他是一个加害者的可能性，
就变得很低，
而另一方面呢，
如果你不是一个受害者，
那么你很可能在某些时刻，
就被化入了加害者的群体，
因为这两者是互斥的，
在人们的道德感之里就是这样的，
所以在这样一个道德的铃合博弈中，
你就会发现，
那人好像必须得去争着当那个受害者，
对吧,
因为如果我不是受害者，
我就很可能变成加害者，
这就是受害者文化的第二个特性，
那就是竞争性，
你会发现，
每当人们在社会互动中，
表达说我受到伤害了，
我是受害者的时候，
他往往不仅仅是说我受到了伤害，
他更常见的表述是，
我比你受到了更多伤害，
我不仅受害，
我比你更受害。
这个观点，
北施大的王方老师和周连老师的，
一场讲座中也有提到，
我觉得起发非常大，
那就是我们现在不仅是要当受害者，
而且是要争当受害者，
我们会发现，
受害者身份的这种，
竞争性出现的时候，
往往是在一种特定的情况下，
那就是，
当一个人或者一个群体，
被指控说你伤害了别人的时候，
他的第一反应，
他对这个指控的回应，
往往不是道歉，
而是宣称，
不对,
我才是那个真正的受害者。
你会发现，
人们不再是以谁对谁错来回应，
他们会通过声称自己遭受了，
更多和更严重的苦难，
回应这种，
我伤害了别人的指责。
这也是为什么，
我们会发现，
在当下社会中，
好像每个人都会觉得自己是受害者。
比如说，
当你讨论，
原生家庭的话题，
你讲到说，
我现在的很多行为模式，
我的不配得感，
我的讨好心人格，
是因为，
在家庭中，
我的父亲或者母亲，
他们曾经怎样对待我，
如果,
跟你的父母，
表达这件事，
讨论这件事的话，
他们一定会把你的众，
表达视作对他们的指责，
给你的回应，
很难是，
我向你道歉，
爸妈妈那时候，
确实不懂，
我确实做错了，
很难是出现这种回应吧，
他们大多数的反应会是，
我为你付出了这么多，
你还觉得不够，
你还不懂得感恩，
还反过来说，
我当年冬天，
给你洗袜子，
怎么怎么样，
你看,
当他感到自己，
被指责，
和被攻击的时候，
他的下意识的回应状态是，
我也受了很多伤，
你怎么可以，
反过来批评我呢，
很明显，
你自己得看出，
这是一种被动的防御，
讲述自己的苦难，
并认为自己比别人受的苦，
更多成为了被攻击，
使了一个被动防御。
首先,
你会发现在，
刚才我们所说的这一场，
你和父母之间的，
受害对受害，
攻击对攻击，
的这样一场对话中，
其实是有一些误解存在的，
也许一开始，
你讲到，
原生家庭带给你的伤害，
并不一定是，
为了指责和攻击他们，
你可能只是想要理解清楚，
我身上这种，
让我感到痛苦的，
不配得感，
到底是为什么？
他来自哪里？
我想看清我自己，
理解我自己，
他能不能帮助我，
更好的成长，
所以我在探索这件事，
那在探索了过程中，
他的确指向了，
其中一个原因，
是他人，是外部，
譬如父母。
你在讲述这件事的时候，
他可能指向的是一种表达，
以及是一种，
需求被看见，
他并不一定完全，
是一种志泽，
但他就导向另一个，
很重要的社会现实，
就是我们正生活在一个，
对他人的志泽和攻击，
极度敏感的时代。
你的父母很容易，
会把你只是单纯地，
提出一个需求，
或者一种感受的表达，
就理解为你是在骂他，
你是在批评他和攻击他，
所以他就会陷入，
一种不安全感，
因而他就会说，
我明明比你更惨，
来进行反驳。
而当父母这样说的时候，
身为孩子的你，
还能怎么办呢？
你当然也会说，
啊可是，
你的确给我造成很多痛苦啊，
我青春期的时候，
怎么怎么样，
你们从来都不知道，
于是很明确，
他就会进入一个比惨的循环，
我比你更惨，
你比我更惨，
每个人都把对方惨这件事，
当做了对自己感受的否认，
和对自己的攻击，
所以你只能把说，
我比你更惨，
作为一种回应和防御的方式，
于是就成为了一种竞争的恶性循环。
不只是在家庭关系中是这样，
在亲密关系，
在所有我们讨论的社会互动，
尤其是人际关系的议题上，
很多时候，
矛盾都是由此产生的，
有一篇2012年发表的，
由美国社会性的学家所做的论文里面，
他们做了一些实验研究，
也验证了这个观点。
他们通过五个实验，
在不同的群体，
不同的场景里去反复验证，
得出了一个结论，
都是说，
不管是男性、女性之间，
学生、教职工之间，
白人、黑人之间，
年轻人和老年人之间，
在所有的群体，
不管高、低位、低位，
只要是人，
只要被接受到一个信息说，
你对他人造成了伤害，
他的这种，
我也被欺负了，
我也受伤了，
甚至是我被反向歧视了，
的这种心理委屈感，
会直线飙升，
这个数值会大幅提高。
所以他其实也解释了一个，
让人有一些困惑的现象，
就是为什么有时候，
我们会发现一些，
客观上处于优势地位的人，
比如说明星、
高学历者，
受传赚钱很多的人，
在一些舆论风波里面，
他们也会真诚地，
感到自己是受害者，
甚至不是一种表演，
也不是一种公关策略，
而是一种，
非常真实的心理体验，
那就是，
明明我比你更受害。
这个研究里面有，
三个实验例子，
我觉得很有意思，
可以拿出来跟大家说。
第一个实验测试的是，
男性和女性，
他们让49名男大学生，
随机分配，
阅读三篇文章，
这三篇文章分别讲的是，
一，女性没有受到歧视，
二，女性受到了歧视，
但主要原因在于，
女性内部，
是女性自己的生理原因，
和选择导致的。
三，女性受到歧视，
并且主要原因是，
由于男性的行为，
把这三篇文章，
给一些男性来看，
看完之后去测量，
他们认为，
男性在这个社会上，
受到歧视的程度，
也就是，
这些背试，
他们自己认为，
自己是一个受害者群体的程度，
那结果是，
在这三篇文章中，
只有在读完了最后一篇，
就是说，
女性的不公对待，
是由于男性造成的，
读完这篇文章的，
男性背试，
会显著的提高，
认为自己是受害者，
程度的评分。
而读另外两组的人，
就没有这个感受。
以及他们这种，
心态的变化，
和他认为，
受害者应该获得更多的，
物质赔偿，
是完全无关的。
也就是说，
他所经历的这个，
心理反应，
并不是说，
希望外界认为，
我做一个男性更受害，
因为我需要赔偿，
而是说，
他是一种，
对道德指控的回击，
他所要补上的是，
内心的那种，
道德缺口，
和道德不安全杠，
他更多是一种，
被动的防御。
还有一个实验，
很有意思的是，
在年轻人，
和老年人之间，
他们找了52个年轻人，
来做实验，
并且给每个人，
都告诉我一个，
社会现实，
那就是，
这个社会，
就是,
更加尊重年轻人，
更加看不起老年人，
每个人都被告知了，
这样一个信息，
但是其中，
有一半的人，
同时被告知说，
但是年轻人自己，
也在这个社会上，
受到歧视，
他们的委屈，
另一半人，
没有收到这个消息，
结论也非常明显，
在那一半被告知说，
虽然这个社会上，
年轻人歧视老年人，
但是这个社会，
也歧视年轻人，
我们年轻人，
也是某个角度上的，
受害者的，
这群被视，
他们然起这种，
迫切地要证明，
我受到很多伤害，
的数值，
会显著降低，
以及他们对于，
我伤害了老年人群体，
集体内疚感的，
数值,
也显着降低，
所以他非常有意思的说明，
人们竞争受害者身份，
这个竞争性，
它本身是有某种功能的，
它其实是一种，
心理上的道德解读剂，
能够让人从，
我是加害者的，
这种认知中解脱出来，
能够重新，
赋予人们一种安全感，
叫做,
我不是一个坏人，
我是一个好人，
而这种道德安全感的，
重要性，
在当下社会，
是被赋予的，
极高，极高的，
所以我们会看到，
竞争受害者身份，
的这个竞争性，
它本质上有这样几个功能，
一是让人，
减少自己的内疚感，
通过强调自己的苦难，
你可以摆脱这种，
你伤害了他人，
带来的集体内疚，
你可以重新，
夺回一个道德至高点，
重新把这个美德属性的光环，
环到自己身上，
更重要的是，
当你重新拥有了，
这个美德的身份之后，
你就可以抵消某种，
他人对你的道德索赔，
因为我也是受害者，
所以我就不欠你们的，
我会发现，
好像我欠了你什么，
对这种委屈感，
其实是社会互动中一个，
非常容易出现的心理，
也是导致我们，
很多行为的一个心理，
比如说，
当女性在谈论复权制，
对他们的伤害的时候，
男性群体会觉得自己被指责了，
因为在男性的心理，
他会把这件事，
识别为，
迷迷我什么都没做，
难道因为我是一个男性，
我生来就欠你们的吗？
这会带来一种，
牺牲委屈和不公平感，
他并不想欠别人什么东西，
所以他本能的防御机制就是，
我也受到很多伤害，
我还要花很多钱交材力，
我还得买房买车，
所以我不欠你们任何东西，
这就解决了，
为什么在当前的大多数，
社会讨论对话中，
冲突往往会演变成一种，
互相比惨的僵局和循环，
每个人都在反复地说，
我比你更惨，
我比你更受害，
就进入了一种冲突的死循环，
因为他其实是，
每个人都激发了，
一种被动性的防御，
他其实和物质利益无关，
和你真的能从这个世界上，
要到多少物质赔偿无关，
也和对方的痛苦程度无关，
他只跟对你自己道德身份的威胁感有关，
也就是说，
所有的比惨，
并不是真的在比较和计算谁更惨，
而只是以比惨这种形式，
来争夺一种道德上的安全感，
因为在当下，
我在道德上是清白的，
我是一个好人，
我不欠任何人任何东西，
这件事，
这种心理状态比几乎。
所有一切其他的安全属性更重要，
道德安全成了一种最高的安全属性。
我想这种安全背后的本质，
其实是一种我的感受的正当性，
因为我们生活在一个。
心理学刚刚成为显学的时代，
有很多工具开始帮助我们。
认识到自己身上的这些痛苦背后的成因，
但是这个社会，
它过往的历史积淀，
我们的上一代人和上上一代人，
以及整个社会结构，
其实没有谁真的有能力在你看见了。
你所受到的伤害之后，
出来给予你一个承认和认可。
宣编几乎很少有人能够。
如你所想要的那样，
给你这种承认和看见吧，
说的确你的感受是合理的，
是正当的，
你在原生家庭中受到很多伤害，
你辛苦了。
我觉得我们宣编很少有人。
有能力说出这样一件事，
可能这也是我们之前节目里聊的。
过年和父母回家吵架，
其实你想从父母嘴里一要到了。
就是这个东西，
但是他们没有这个能力给你，
正因为我们要不到这个东西，
我们的所有痛苦要求。
我们的感受被承认是正当的，
是合理的，
可是却没有人能承认。
它是正当的，是合理的。
所以我们好像就只能去和别人比。
如果我无法被确认说。
我的感受是正当的，
那么似乎我能做的就只有。
去和你竞争说
我的感受至少比你更正当，
受到的伤害比你更多，
所以我更值得被人看见，
就成了一种我们能获得的最低限度的，
给予自己一点点外部力量的看见，
支持和承认的安全感的来源。
所以受害者敘事背后的这种竞争性。
也解答了我很长时间以来的一个困惑，
那就是我们的社会，
它的心理结构到底是。
募强还是彼惨，
到底哪个是大家更需要的，
因为很多时候你会发现。
受害者其实会被看作是一个弱者，
有些时候大家对一些真正的受害者和弱者，
比如残疾人，是不愿意去看的，
或者不愿意展露出自己这种程度的脆弱的，
大家更希望自己是一个强大的人，
是一个强者，
但在另一些时候，
大家又会急于展现自己的脆弱，
把自己放置到一个受害者的位置上。
带着刚才的理解，
我们就会发现，
其实是因为这里的弱，
这里的弱并不是真正的弱，
受害也不是真的受害，
而是通过展现受害的位置，
所获得的一种身份，
或者是一种道德资本，
因而不管是强还是弱，
不管是募强还是彼惨，
本质上都是希望自己能够。
被看见，被承认，
和对自己身份地位的确认，
以及当他人对自己的身份地位产生否认，
不管是你是一个强者的身份被否认，
还是你是一个美德受害者的身份被否认，
会激发的一种剧烈反弹，
一种强烈的委屈感和不公平感，
那应对这种委屈的反应，
就是我们刚刚所说的，
作为被动防御，
是的是去竞争说我更受害。
说到这里，
其实我们可以看到，
不管是说，
我们当下对他人的表达，
他人的指责和攻击，
正在变得越来越敏感和警惕，
还是说，
我们会习惯性地用我更受害，
来应对他人的攻击和指责。
他本质上都是一种防御。
防御是什么意思？
他的意思是，
你现在的内心是一个不完整的，
不安全的，不整权的状态。
用荣格或者弗勒德的话说，
他是一个人个体性，
或者自体化，
还没有真正完成的状态。
用当下流行的话说，
就是一个人的主体性，
还没有真正确立，
一个人还没有强大到说，
他构建了一个稳定的自我，
我知道我是谁，
我要的是什么的，
这样一个相对健康和整权的状态。
他处在一个有缺失的，
有缺口的不安全感的状态，
而他这个状态下，
你在一个不安全的环境里面，
用受害者叙事来进行某种防御，
就成了一种本能的应激反应。
就像我们刚刚所看到的，
他并不会真的带来任何改变，
也并不会真的让你得到你所期待的那种，
被认可和被看见。
他只会陷入一个恶性竞争的死循环。
所以我想我们在这里本质上，
是在对受害者文化进行一种反思。
他并不能帮助我们真正的。
填补起内心的那个缺口，
让我们成长成一个完整的自我，
继续往前走。
用我那种在看到了创伤和痛苦之后，
真正改变他和脱离他的力量。
但我同样想强调的是，
这里也存在另外一个陷阱，
那就是当我们说要警惕受害者叙事，
反思受害者叙事的时候。
它是否意味着我们就要。
划下光谱的另一端，叫做，
那么我们就不要谈论和理解彼此的。
创伤和脆弱。
我们就不要展现你在受害者这个位置上的弱者的处境。
这是我前两年看大家讨论。
弱女叙事这件事时，
一个非常大的感受啊，
就是女性在当下的复权之结构中。
是处于受害者位置的。
那么像房斯奇的初恋乐园这样的书籍，
描述和展现女性在这个结构中的受害位置，
告诉人们揭示出这个结构是如何伤害女性的。
这样的表达是否是一种弱女叙事，
是否是弱的，需要被病气的，
因为她对让女性变得更强大，没有帮助呢？
我想一定不是这样的。
我们今天所有讨论的一个巨大的前提，
一定是说，
如果是一个结构性的弱势群体，
并且他们仍然处在这个结构中的弱势位置，
仍在被伤害者。
那么他们的这种敏感性，
他们对伤害的敏感是要被一个真正文明的社会优先保护的。
也就是说，第一步，在结构中受到伤害的人，
他需要自己的伤害被看见，被理解，
这是完全正当的，合理的。
也是我们每个人都需要，
我也希望大家能够去善意地提供给他人的看见，
承认，承认彼此受到伤害，并给予彼此帮助和理解。
这是一个社会的理想途径。
那么在给予这种看见伤害的帮助同时，
我们的确需要意识到说，
如果过度的强调自己的受害者心态变成一种自廉，
或者自磨，它是需要警惕的。
但它之所以需要警惕，
不是因为某种标签，或者结论和主义，
而是因为我们讲述自己受到伤害这件事，
本质上也是希望能够理解清自己的痛苦，
从而摆脱痛苦走出来。
但是过度的沉浸在和将自己困在、束缚在这种受害者心态里面，
并不能真的帮我们摆脱痛苦。
它并不能获得我们一开始所期待的那种自由和解脱，
让我们获得力量继续往前走。
它甚至不一定是一定要解决问题。
我觉得判断标准不是说它有没有用，
有没有改变当下立刻发生变化的可能性，
而是说它能不能赋予你力量，
让你在看清痛苦之后继续往前。
人不看清痛苦是一定不可能获得力量的，
所以看清和承认伤害是必要的。
但是在看清和承认伤害之后，
我们有没有获得这种力量，
有没有帮助我们站起来继续往前走，
这也是很重要的。
但承认这种重要性并不意味着我们对受害者心态的反思。
就直接等同于谴责弱者，或者谴责弱女。
谴责人们说你不能生成自己是弱的，
因为这样没有用，
你只有变得更加强大才能解决问题。
我觉得这是一个更加严重的陷阱，
那就是警惕受害者心态不应该变成另一种攻击和谴责他人的方式。
反思受害者叙事并不是只想说让我们简单粗暴地成为强者，
把受害者放在弱者的位置上，
而我们必须要成为一个强者，
以及攻击那些仍然在叙述自己的创伤，
希望自己的伤害被看见的人，
这两者之间有非常广貌的地带，
那就是同理性的地带。
我们谈论这件事，
我们思考这件事不是为了找到一个对错，
而我做这件对的事，批评那些做的不对的人，
我们不是为了谴责，不是为了宣扬自己更胜利，
而是为了帮助和理解。
所以我想今天我们讨论受害者文化这件事，
背后我们想讨论的根本问题其实是，
我们到底应该如何理解我们所面对的痛苦。
当我们有如此多的解释工具帮助我们看清了它，
之后我们到底能怎么办？
很重要的一点是，我们并不是要指责个体或者个人，
因为受害者序式的流行并不只是一个个体的心理现象，
是因为它有各种的历史政治积累，
是社会逐渐演变成了当今这样一个富裕受害者身份，
以最高最真实的道德权威和政治价值的时代，
所以在这样的一个社会环境下争夺这个身份就必然变得不可避免。
它并不是说人类在这个世代突然变得更脆弱和更自私了，
我觉得它本质上是对一套社会激励结构做出的反应和回应，
是因为当下的社会互动或者社会结构它无力给予更多的东西，
它只能够给予一种道德奖势上，
所以人们才会去争夺这个道德资本。
所以我想当我们谈论说我们该如何理解在当下的社会现实中我们所面临的痛苦，
我们所感受到的这种真实的情感的时候，
我们需要看到它背后是有一个大的社会结构转型和理解脉络的学科转型的。
比如我们现在大家开始需要用社学的理论来解释说我的生活到底怎么了，
为什么会变成这样。
但是整个社会学的学科发展是具有它的一个内在特点的，
那就是从上个世纪七八十年代八九十年代开始，
美国社会学的学科发展式就倾向于结构批判的理论。
社会学这个学科会更大概率的倾向于用结构的视角，
一个更宏观的视角来理解说社会生活中运转的各项事物，
各种冲突和矛盾是怎么发生的。
当人们长期接受的是这样的学科视角的时候，
你不可避免的就会产生这样一个想法叫做，
那我所感受到痛苦是需要外部有一个东西来负责的吧。
于是它一步一步的就会在人性的滑漆上滑向这样一个维度叫做，
那我是结构的受害者，需要有结构为此负责。
我没有做错什么，是一个外部的世界做错了什么。
另一方面，在这个光谱的另一端，
同样圣肖臣上的就是我们时代的另一个显学，
身心灵。和社会科学这种结构批判的是脚截然相反。
身心灵简单粗暴地讲它说服人或者给予人安慰的方式是，
所有的苦难都被个人化了。
比如说凡事发生皆有利于我，我不是要否认这句话，
我很多时候也被这句话帮助，
但我们看凡事发生皆有利于我，
它背后的意思其实是说你所有经受的苦难和痛苦，
都是你自我起升的契机，你的苦难是合理的，
但是实在你的个人内部是合理的，
你是要自己为这些苦难负责，不能够推给外部社会，
因为推过去也没用，
而我们对这种个人负责的合理化就是，
它最终是来助我的，是帮助我成长和提升的。
非常明显的是这两者，
不管是所有问题都是外部和结构的错，
还是说所有问题都是我自己应该为此负责的，
我的苦难都是我应得的。
这两个思路是并不能兼容的，
也并不能用其中任何一个来完整的解释整套社会生活。
推万不讲，至少它很难被推击及人，对吧？
你也很难说哪一套更应该被用来要求自己，
但同时又能够被推广到他人身上，
推广到社会群体的身上，
它之间是有一些不兼容的东西的，
但是这两者正在以同样的速度在社会上兴起，
人们对于这两者的需求度是同样高涨的。
所以它反映的是，无论用哪一种解释规范，
用哪一种理解方法，
我们都一定需要自己的苦难被看见，
以及被某种方式清晰的解释，
不然我们没有办法再继续生活下去。
那么回到我们自己身上，
当我们能够带有反思性的去理解这一套东西，
理解受害者文化的流行和它背后的问题之后，
我们必须还得面对的时常生活中的一个问题，
那就是，我的痛苦仍然在呀，
面对我的这些痛苦和这些疮伤，
我还能不能说，以及我该怎么说？
我在原生家庭里的疮伤，
我在亲密关系里所受到的伤害，
我在这个线别结构里所受到的影响，
死我这些东西，我现在到底该怎么面对它呢？
我想讲述这些事儿，
希望自己的痛苦被承认和被看见，
它背后到底是一种能够带来力量的自我理解，自我探索，
成长的一步一环，
还是说它是一种自理言自谋，
它这根本的分也在于你情留在哪里？
你所想要看见的和你想要被看见的，
到底是一个真实的自我，还是一种身份？
身份的意思是，它并不只是你这个人，
并不只是你真实的经验感受和共识，
而是一种资本。
它是在向外界索取某种东西，
索取某种赔偿和补偿，
来填补你内心那种圣大的无法补上的不安全感。
它是一个人在不安全状态下所做出的一种防御，
也就是一种变形。
索取并不是问题，
问题是你需要意识到索取这个变形的动作，
并不能真的让你索取到你想要的那个东西，
因为你要的那个东西只有你自己能给你。
所以我们对自己创伤的理解对痛苦的表达，
到底该以怎样的方式去面对，
它的重点在于你情留在哪里？
你的表达是一种防御的开始，
还是一种防御的结束？
我们仍然可以表达、分析，
理解我们的痛苦，看清我们自己，
因为它是我们最终了解自己是谁，
成为自己，
将自己的自我能够真正的健康的整合起来的一种努力，
它是努力的过程中，毕竟的一环。
但真正重要的是，
它并不是奢求一种欲望的满足，
而只要求一种表达本身的完成，
它产生的是理解，而不是控制。
控制是一种防御，
而理解是一种自然的，
帮助你的自我健康成长和生发的力量。
我想，总有一天，
我们能做到的也许是，
我们能承认自己的痛苦，
但这种承认并不一定以。
有一个他人和外界。
来满足你被看见的欲望作为前提。
总有一天，
我们能自己赋予自己内心的力量，
而不再以
寻求某种更优势的身份，
无论是强者身份，
还是受害者身份为前提。
这不是某种新的道德标准，
或者更高的社会资本，
而是说，
只有这样才是一种对我们自己。
更加温柔的，
更加尊重的，
更加平等的，
真正的理解和看见。
好呀，那我们今天这期节目。
就先聊到这里。
如果大家关于受害者文化。
有什么想要讨论和分享的话题，
也欢迎在评论区给我留言。
我们下期节目再见，
拜拜。